we all have a stake in the future of our  planet  and how the food we eat impacts our  health and the environment  with food supplies which are not only  secure but sustainable too  that's why the eu is supporting a global  transformation  in how we produce  distribute  and consume our food  establishing green alliances with our  global partners to promote biodiversity  and responsible production  and setting new standards which will put  sustainability at the heart of food  production worldwide  in the interests of the citizens of the  eu  and the world  a durable future for the food we eat  and the people behind it  by acting together we can all change our  way of eating into a sustainable way of  life  from farm  to fork  do you have the appetite for change  [Music]  you